one elected officials understanding of
policing and racial issues doesn't come
from books or news reports
it's his lived experience as a young
victim of a police speeding who later
served more than 20 years as a New York
City police officer Eric Adams went on
to serve in the New York State Senate
and is now the Brooklyn borough
president he walked with protesters in
marches this week and he also took time
to speak with me about his unique
perspective on policing protesting and
change as I'm out walking the streets
with the protest I'm hearing the pain
and anger and we're yelling at each
other
and we're not even hearing or seeing
each other we're so immersed in pain how
do we change that Eric you've been on
here on both sides you were a police
officer in New York City you are
obviously a black man who lives in
Brooklyn you are the borough president
here how do we start communicating I
know what it is to be spit at I know
what it is to have people call you Uncle
Tom and hate you and I realize it was
just a few minutes ago I was marching
next to you but we could change it by
being sincere in the moment the first
steps towards recovery is acknowledging
their problems were having and policing
in our country and we're not willing to
do that yet hopefully this will allow us
to do so where does that acknowledgement
have to come from is it literally each
member of the force looking at himself
or is it broader than that we have to
create a culture of zero tolerance for
those who want to come into this noble
profession the noble profession has been
hijacked with people who want to use
they abuse their insecurities it's
unfortunate that many of the individuals
who move up through the ranks
they were abusive and so if you have
them moving up through the ranks they
just stayed there well you know that's
just just good old boys having fun are
there things to do to hold police that
are abusive more accountable
and perhaps change things yes but that
accountability starts rarely at the top
we're very slow and weeding out those
officers who are abusive the Minnesota
case is a very important case all the
officers who were involved were also
indicted we said you are your brother's
keeper not only do you have an
obligation to stop a person that's not a
cop from committing a crime you have an
obligation and responsibility to stop
your brother officer from committing a
crime when you were on the force did you
feel that that was the message no not at
all that was not the message in fact if
you did it you would be targeted and you
would be tocall the rat you will be
called someone that is hurting the blue
a uniform or the blue wall it was just
the opposite do you think that's the
situation or the climate that we're in
now it is it is still there so we must
have mechanism in place where an officer
can clearly number one stop abuse from
happening immediately number two be able
to report it without jeopardizing his
public safety at the same time because
policing is real fighting crime is real
the New York Police Department has taken
criticism for the way it's handled some
of the things one person described it as
overly aggressive with the peaceful
protesters and not aggressive enough
with that criminal element why are we
seeing that potentially policing is the
only profession that we state if you're
in the career you could do every job in
the career and that is not true because
you are know how to fight crime doesn't
mean you know how to deal with a
sensitive issue like handling protests
we have to change how we assign police
officers and be honest in doing so then
you see these officers who are receiving
an onslaught of insult and they are
poise they handle themselves well they
really deescalate situations and then
you look at others who spent a lifetime
of only going through kicking in doors
going after bad guys with guns and in
their mind everyone is a bad guy and if
we don't understand that then we're
never going to get this right on these
sensitive times people want to do
something what is that first step
change where we are as a society I think
the first step is on two sides first the
police have they must be ready for real
reform and they cannot say here's what
we're going to do they need to identify
the national and local leaders and sit
down and hear from them what are you
looking for you know communication is
everything we need to really communicate
when not communicating second I'm
encouraging parents to march with their
children to be there this is a teaching
moment for us all we've been here before
does this time feel different to you I
think the reason is different now
because Floyd wasn't first we are Zongo
we're Diallo we're Louima this is not
new I personally believe that people are
feeling black right now
I think our national dialogue is making
people feel as though they're black I
think coronavirus and watching the lack
of access to health care is making
people feel they're black I think all of
a sudden going to school and getting
your secondary degree and now you don't
have a job they're feeling black and so
when they hear the term black lives
matter I think they actually hearing
that their lives matter and speaking
with him was really eye-opening in so
many ways one of the things when Shelly
said that can change in policing right
away change the commander status they
need more local input maybe even look
outside of the police force for that and
then stop one of the things I heard in
your piece this reward system it's not
about the arrests and summonses it needs
to be about the impact you're having on
the community and again in your piece so
many of the things that I heard Eric say
were also the things that were being
said there yeah he's coming at it from
all sides he's passionate about it I've
seen him in action Thank You Dana great
conversation